During his two terms as governor of
Arizona, Doug Ducey did an awful
lot. He managed to pass a flat
income tax with a rate of 2.5%, he
reformed public sector pensions,
universalized some of the most
important school choice measures in
the state, reformed occupational
licensing rules, and turned a budget
deficit into a surplus.
He substantially reduced the size
of the state's government workforce
as well. He built a makeshift border
wall though out of shipping crates
and pushed back on marijuana
legalization.
And he was accused by his
constituents of doing both too much
and too little during COVID.
Today, he runs Citizens for Free
Enterprise. In December, he received
Reason's Savas Award for
Privatization, which is given
annually to someone who is advancing
innovative ways to improve the
provision and quality of public
services by engaging the private
sector. When he was in town, the
governor and I sat down to talk
about his time in office, his
worries about the future of the
Republican Party, his commitment to
fusionism, and why Arizona
politicians are so weird.
Thank you for joining us, Governor.
We are excited to talk with you here
at Reason today.
Good to be here.
Good. Thanks for having me.
Let's start just right into
it. Arizona politicians
are kind of built different.
What is it about Arizona that
seems to just generate a little
bit of a kind of heterodox
or unorthodox politician, would you
say?
Yeah, I don't know.
I think it's a good question.
I think maybe the fact that we're
the youngest state in the lower
48, that we're
a place where so many people
came to live.
So few people that are there today
were actually born there.
So people make that decision.
And then I think there's something
about the West in the spirit of
Barry Goldwater, where it brings
an independent mindedness to
it.
Arizona has been red of
late, but it's trending blue.
What do you what do you attribute
that to?
Candidates matter.
I would actually push back pretty
hard on where
it is. I was able
to win in 2014 with
the wind at my back and
win by a larger margin
in 2018
with the wind in my face.
What was it really a tough year
for conservatives and
Republicans around the country.
And I was also able to capture
44% of the
Hispanic vote against an
opponent named David Garcia.
So if you have the right candidate
who's talking about common sense
kitchen table issues and
actually persuading the electorate,
I think the state is still
a center-right state.
If you have somebody that wants to
come and relitigate 2020
and only speak to the base, that's
a losing message.
You campaigned in your first
campaign on bringing taxes in
Arizona as close as possible to
zero, and you
got to 2.5%
flat tax in the end.
How did you do that?
I feel like as long as I have been
involved in kind
of free market or small
government politics, people have
been talking about low tax,
flat tax. You're going to do your
taxes on a postcard.
Usually more talk than action.
So what happened?
Persistence, persistence,
persistence.
It was our goal.
Every year we lowered or simplified
taxes and we actually
had the left overreach and
came into Arizona and I think
deceived the voters
with an initiative saying
we can put a billion dollars
additional into K-12 education
and it won't cost you any money.
Only the rich people.
And they took our 4.5%
tax at the highest progressive
level to eight.
Now, 8% in Arizona would
have been a cancer that would have
metastasized over decades.
That's Bernie Sanders' Vermont,
Washington, D.C., or
New York State.
But it was popular.
We worked hard to beat it.
It was polling at about 65-35.
We were able to drive it down to
51%
on Election Day.
But when I was a when I was a young
boy, there was a show on Saturday
morning, Wild World of Sports.
And they would talk about the thrill
of victory and the agony
of defeat.
We suffered about 18 months
of the agony of defeat while
we challenged the initiative in
court. It eventually got to
our Supreme Court, and then we
reformed taxes in
the legislature.
In the interim, the law,
the initiative was struck down
and we had reduced taxes along
the way. So had we
been successful on Election Day,
taxes in Arizona today would be
4.5%.
But because we had a bad result,
we persisted
in the legislature and we had a
Supreme Court that was not going to
let out-of-state interest deceive
the voter.
Today, we have the lowest flat tax
in the nation.
So I would say a combination of
good planning, good
timing,and good luck.